June 2006
pulao a remote chain of islands in the
Pacific Ocean
National Geographic scientists Lee
Berger has come here on vacation on the
final day of his trip he his wings of a
possible discovery of fossilized human
remains nearby a local guide takes lead
to a natural cave on one of the smallest
islands
the guy takes lead to a small pile of
bones he knows right away that they are
human but just what as he stumbled into
he realizes the bones are extremely
unusual the piece of skull has a
pronounced brow Ridge very different
from the average of modern human
the bone is also incredibly thick in the
shape of the for the wide nose and small
eyes would have meant a strange flat
face nothing like Paulo has come to have
perhaps most interesting of all is the
skull size it's about 25% smaller than
that of an average adult human today
this region it's a compact body the wide
nose of the parents we have looked at
unist freakish
after three days in the lab Berger and
his team are starting to believe that
these bones are not the remains of an
ancient people at all but a tribe of
previously unknown lived in modern times
this would be the first evidence of such
an evolution that diverse people living
alongside modern humans in recent times
the team would know for sure until
samples have been carbon-dated but
they're beginning to suspect that these
unusual-looking cave people could have
populated the earth in just three
thousand years ago possibly surviving it
as recently as 500 AD
scientists can only speculate but the
what-ifs are extraordinary did these
cave people resemble us in hiding
parents and somehow goofs more in order
to adapt to a difficult environment
although they small when they are
perhaps the answer is the simplicity
pleasant enough comment with no crops or
animals and these people
officials
their bodies and brain cavities
shrinking due to a lack of protein and
other basic nutrients evidence shows
that the earliest circle has arrived in
Palau just three to four thousand years
ago subsequent generations might have
adapted to the harsh conditions but it
seems to have happened very quickly this
would mean that rather than humans
evolving were the tens of thousands
as previously thought these little
people could have changed drastically in
size and shape in just a few hundred
years